well first of all the government takes
this very seriously and i can understand
that your your viewers and you will be
concerned about this new variant that's
why we've introduced a range of new
restrictions already which we think are
proportionate for example in relation to
travel and in relation to mask wearing
that's why we analyze the the virus and
that's happening for example at portland
down now
but in the meantime the message to
people i think is
fairly straightforward which is keep
calm carry on with your christmas plans
we've put the necessary restrictions in
place but beyond that keep calm and
carry on it's interesting you say carry
on with your christmas plans this is
exactly what the prime minister boris
johnson's also saying saying go ahead
with your christmas parties if you so
wish but actually jenny harris who's of
course the head of the uk health
security agency says that people should
cut back on unnecessary socializing over
the festive period but on the other hand
the prime minister's saying go ahead and
party on so
it seems that you're out of step then
with what the scientists are saying
well well all of our
advice is based on scientific evidence
and indeed the the chief medical officer
and the chief scientific advisor attends
cabinet was at cabinet when we discussed
this earlier this week that's why we've
gone for this balanced and proportionate
set of measures so it is the case that
unlike previously in england people will
have to wear masks on public transport
and they'll have to wear masks in retail
settings we've very much timed up the
border restrictions but beyond that
we believe that those are necessarily
appropriate steps but beyond that people
can carry on with their plans as before
so i would say to people just keep calm
carry on with your christmas plans as as
already set out this morning we're just
learning this actually quite a large
number of organizations a few are
canceling their plans and people are not
listening to what you're saying do you
think that people are just not trusting
what you're saying they just don't have
much confidence so in what you're saying
so some of the people we're hearing
university college london nhs trusts age
uk these are all organizations
government departments that have
cancelled their christmas parties
despite the fact that you're saying
carry on
well i understand that people have um
concerns around the new variant that's
why the government has taken the sort of
measures that we've
already outlined but but beyond that as
the prime minister has been at pains to
say several times and said again
yesterday and i'm very happy to
to repeat again this morning we think
those are sufficient at this stage and
beyond that people should continue with
their plans as intended
we've always said that we want people to
have a better christmas than they had
last year we're confident they're able
to do so but the reason people are able
to do so is because of this vaccine so
the one thing that everyone can do if
they're worried is to make sure that
they take that booster that they make
sure that they top up their immunity and
for example the results out this morning
are very promising about the effects of
that booster they vindicate the decision
taken by the government to invest in
buying those doses of pfizer and moderna
so provided people take the booster when
they get the call provided they abide by
the existing rules as as updated in
light of the the new variant i think
people can continue with their christmas
plans and i'd encourage people to do so
well talking about the fact that um a
number of government organizations have
decided to cancel their christmas party
this is certainly having a knock-on
effect financially on the hospitality
industry which is already taking a huge
bathroom during this pandemic are you
going to provide any support for them
during this winter months well we've
already provided a huge amount
well i think the the the support that
we've outlined and by the way some of
that support is is ongoing still for
example in relation to to business rates
been businesses are still benefiting
from that
beyond that we have not changed the
advice around people
uh taking part in hospitality so going
to the pub going to restaurants and so
on and actually i think most pubs and
restaurants up until very recently have
been doing very well during this season
and we're not discouraging people from
continuing to do so they are going to
take a hit though if a lot of people are
canceling their christmas um you know
plans they will be taking a huge hit a
lot of people had been
relying on this christmas festive
season to make up some of the losses
that they've made they've made over the
years so
will you provide extra support for them
during this christmas period well let's
wait and see how we we do over the the
christmas period because the
government's position remains that
people should carry on with their
christmas plans and i understand why
your viewers and and why people up and
down the country will be concerned about
this new variant i want to reassure
people that that is why we have taken
the measures in relation to to travel
that's why we've tightened some of the
rules around mask wearing but why we're
taking a proportionate approach whilst
we consider
the effects of this this variant and
what
and by that i mean that the uh port and
down and others are examining this for
us to understand exactly it's its
implications whilst that's going on we
believe these are neces these are
appropriate steps they're sufficient for
now to enable people to continue with
their christmas plans as before okay now
we're just hearing of families who are
being stranded in south africa obviously
it's on the redless country and this is
because they're not
enough hotel rooms for them to
quarantine in when they reach the uk so
it looks like a lot of people will be
spending their christmases in those
southern african countries which you
have put on the red list and it appears
that you put the restrictions in place
overnight but you didn't readjust or
look out for the um capacity for the
existing infrastructure plan
well we do have to take the risks
associated with this new variant
seriously and i don't want to impose any
restrictions the government doesn't want
to impose any more restrictions than
necessary but because of the uh origins
of this virus in southern africa we had
to move rapidly to um impose those
restrictions on south africa that's why
we did it immediately of course we'll
make sure that the appropriate
facilities are in in place for people
but the reason why we did that and the
reason this whole strategy is about
making sure that we limit uh the spread
of the omnichrome omicron variant at
this stage whilst we we look at the
effects of it which in turn enables me
to be able to say that people can keep
calm and carry on with their christmas
plans because we're taking tough
measures in relation to the virus coming
into the country through at-risk
countries so you have enough rooms
available then if people in southern
africa are wanting to come here and to
isolate in hotels will there be enough
hotel rooms well of course there's a
difference in the between um
nationals of southern african countries
who are not allowed to come here uk
nationals
who are returning yes of course we'll
make sure that we we have appropriate
provisions so those people who are
stranded we can say to them come home
it's absolutely fine the minister says
there will be enough rooms for you yes
so
so what i say to those people is clearly
they have to abide by the new rules
which means that when they return they
have to immediately hotel quarantine
they have to have their pcr on day two
and day eight and of course we will make
sure that there are uh appropriate hotel
quarantine facilities in place we ramped
those up last time we'll make sure we
continue to do so okay well let's step
away from coving and let's talk about
the by-election which is taking place in
old bexley and sidcup their 10 swing to
labor now this is supposed to be a safe
tourist seat 10 is nothing to be sniffed
at
well look this is a good result for a
governing party midterm as you well know
governing parties shouldn't expect to do
well midterm we actually secured over 50
percent of the vote in in bexley and i
pay tribute to our excellent candidate
and the campaign team there that secured
that result this idea that labour have
made some surge ahead is is really for
the birds they've actually got about the
same vote share as they secured under
jeremy corbyn in 2017 and kirsten
couldn't even be bothered to turn up to
the the by-election so i'm i'm i'm
really not terribly worried about labour
the fact is they did make some some
gains there and one of the things that
kept coming up um was the allegations of
sleaze which is what kept coming up on
the doorstep do you think that that's
something that's had a bit of a knock-on
effect on your numbers well of course
people have concerns uh mid-term with
any government's performance and of
course people have been concerned about
what's happened over the past couple of
months but i actually think it's tribute
contrary to a lot of expectations to the
campaign that has been fought uh by
louis french by the the excellent team
down there that we secured 50 of those
now what i take from that is that the
government has to focus and get on with
delivery that's why for example just
next week we'll be taking action to
address one of people's concerns around
small boats with a new nationality and
borders legislation that will come
before parliament again and i very much
hope that labour and the liberal
democrats will actually support that
legislation because it's essential to
tackle this problem the turnout was very
low wasn't it it was only 34
yes i mean it is the case that in
by-elections turnout tends to be low but
against that backdrop we we managed to
secure 50 and i really want to thank the
people of bexley for putting their faith
in louis and putting their faith in the
government let's talk about the french
prime minister then rejecting boris
johnson's call for joint uk french
patrols in the channel
we have a crisis here don't we and the
two people who should be coming together
to solve this are just not getting along
where do we go from here
well there's two elements first of all
we need to get our laws in the right
place so they're not currently fit for
purpose and that's why we're bringing
forward the the nationality and balls is
built for example which will uh increase
to a maximum life sentence for those
vile people traffickers who are
exploiting vulnerable people crossing
from one safe country france to another
safe country the uk it has a range of
other measures for example in relation
to increasing the sanctions for
illegally entering the uk so it's
essential we get that through and it's
essential by the way we get support from
other parties for that when that comes
before parliament next week we also have
to have international cooperation now
the home secretary is already this week
has been meeting i believe with her
dutch counterparts and with her italian
counterparts to stop this flow of
migration and we continue to cooperate
with the french we cooperate with the
french in many different ways including
in uh in nato uh in relation to uh joint
intelligence operations so there's a lot
of anglo-french cooperation going on and
actually if you look we have managed
through that corporation to stop 20 000
boats crossing the channel i hope that
cooperation will continue
do you think that the allegations of
fleas and also the crisis that we're
seeing over the migrants issue in the
channel will haunt you when it comes to
the next election general election well
i think it's essential that we address
the
uh challenge of of migrants the the um
the small boats but that is precisely
why we're bringing forward this
legislation to toughen up our laws next
week so the challenge is will other
parties support us in that legislation
will the liberal democrats enable
supporters in that legislation when it
comes before parliament next week